one of the biggest
challenges during the pandemic has been
keeping an eye
on vulnerable children parents are
saying that they don't want the child at
home anymore they want him accommodated
we've been allowed inside britain's
biggest social work department
at kent county council dad has a bad
weekend and then he'll say i can't have
him anymore and then
things will settle and then they're in a
bit of a circle
when the phone rings here it means
there's an immediate concern for the
welfare of a child
people think that pr means parental
rights it doesn't it means parental
responsibility
your responsibility to your child and
people turn up here with their child
stuff in a black sack and just say i
don't want to
take them yeah and it's one of the
things i really struggle with as a
social worker
we carried out a national poll of social
workers
and nearly half 45 percent said the
number of children being put on child
protection plans is up compared to the
same period last year
and the majority 80 percent said they
didn't feel like they had enough
resources
to cope with the level of demand they
now face
but she's basically said that her mum
has been using drugs
um and there's sort of syringes in all
sorts around the house
she can't live there anymore and she
wants to go to college she wants to do
some positive things in her life she
just wants
somewhere safe to be all right bye
but the case that's just come in isn't
about a parent
who's had enough of their child it's
about a child
who's had enough of their parent mum's
got a real history of class a drug use
which has got clearly out of control so
here we have a youngster
phoning you guys about her mum that that
was
doesn't happen very often this is
extremely rare
it's the first time that i've certainly
heard of it in my current role
thank you for meeting me in the first
place social worker davina mcmohan
meets the 16 year old in a local park
layla
it's not her real name says during
lockdown her mum's drug use has spiraled
out of control
and she's had enough we've changed her
voice to protect her identity
what would you like to happen what do
you think would be
you'd be happy with that yeah okay
because you've been through that before
yeah and you feel comfortable for that
okay
um because you're 16 you can actually
give your own consent for that to happen
davina
now has to find emergency accommodation
for layla
oh hi sarah it's dee so she's basically
saying that she would she would like a
placement she's reporting that mum
has been using heroin before which is
obviously the concerns and why
they were removed when they're younger
she's been staying with her brother
he's saying that he can't keep her there
he's got two young children there's not
the surprise
leyla's story is one of a childhood
marred by her mother's addiction to
drugs
i thought i could help her so i tried
hanging on for so long
and i realized it just has to end but i
wanted so i tried so hard to just
try and get her through it and make sure
she was okay
and my worry was if i left her would she
go like to drugs harder than what she is
now
and in the end i just said i can't do it
anymore
this must have been a very difficult
decision for you to make
yeah this is your mom but she's done it
before and
i've been used to it
are you wanting that break now yeah
i feel i feel like um it will help as
well
so i can actually get my life back on
track go to college sort my education
out get a job
and just move on with my life without
her in it
because she's a setback to life with all
of us she's going to set back to life
layla is caught between a rock and a
hard place her home life
hectic but care is far from ideal
all the research tells us that outcomes
for children in care are not great
and so maintaining children within their
families and within their kind of social
network is absolutely key
i think one of the lasting legacies of
this
of lockdown will be on children and
indeed adults mental health
and we're beginning to see that now
we're beginning to see how
um lockdown and all its um is vagaries
has has impacted on on children and
their carers
in the short term the government says
it's given local councils 3.7 billion
pounds
to cope with pressures caused by the
pandemic but the long term is not so
certain last year the government said it
would launch an independent care review
to take a look at the future of
children's social care
one year on and that review is yet to
begin
nick martin sky news kent
you